that's an interesting way to close out
the black museum I know I said I was
gonna go back and do all the old ones
the previous episodes prior to season
four black mirror so that I could catch
the references in the Easter eggs but
you know what enough people told me that
they are just that they are Easter eggs
there are things in the museum that
would have referenced other shows but
it's not plot relevant so I said to heck
with it I'll watch it now and then go
back and watch the old stuff for the
warning you should know this but there
you go so yeah um it's a bit of an odd
duck
this one it's good I enjoyed it it's got
a different vibe it's got you know it
you know what this thing feels like this
feels a lot like Tales from the Crypt
series the the one that was on HBO
I don't want to think about how long ago
it was it'll make me feel old but it
really does have that feel you know
building to you know little bits of sort
of ooh creepy uh unnerving uh building
to an ironic you know
punishment for somebody something that
is you know kind of horrible to think
about but it gets delivered on to
somebody who more or less deserves it so
you're like I'm okay with that
that's right up Tales from the Crypt
Sally and um it also shares a little bit
of a camp aspect which hasn't really
been too much in this show up to this
point largely just embodied by you know
the guy who owns the museum whose name
is suddenly escaping me but um you know
he he he as well as the story overall of
this thing and even the individual ones
as well feels very Tales from the Crypt
ish he's he's a little bit hammy
although not too over-the-top I think
actually he gives a surprisingly
balanced performance it gets a little
bit more campy as it goes along but
that's okay cuz he needs to build up the
villainy so that were okay with what
happens to him at the very end so it
balances pretty well and early on it
would have been very easy for this
character just to be played up straight
creeper like not like creepy but like
why would why would anyone go into a
museum run by this guy and this is just
like everything reads wrong but he's got
a little bit of showmanship to him he's
so you know you can buy that he
he's you know just running this place
and and and initially it's almost like
so you know how much of this is an act
and how much of this is him really being
like that but you see when he comes and
when it really comes out of him you know
what he shows the final exhibit it
explains the attraction that and what
people came to do to that you know day
you realize oh that's not an act that's
he was holding back before so it I liked
the way that that builds as far as he
goes there wasn't really anything about
this episode that particularly surprised
me I think the only thing that I didn't
see coming to some extent was I didn't
see the mother getting put into the
monkey until pretty close to when it
happened that I didn't see coming too
far ahead of time pretty much as soon as
the museum owners started coughing I'm
like she poisoned him she's the guy's
daughter she said she was gonna go see
your father that's the ghost of her
father called it and I was right I
didn't call precisely what was gonna
happen to him I thought it was just
gonna be poison and that would be it so
they took it a step further than that
but like the big twist of that I know I
called not way in advance but like
probably a little sooner than I was
supposed to as at least that it felt
like it was a little sooner that I was
supposed to in terms of how the episode
was unraveling as far as the individual
pieces I mean I feel like in a lot of
ways that this was a repository for
ideas that were black mirror ish but
didn't lend themselves to be expanded
far enough out to make for a whole
episode and but they were ideas that
were good enough to do something with
and so I feel like this they just built
a you know an overarching story around
well we've got these ideas that aren't
gonna get us a full episode oh well cram
them in here and it may or may not have
been that contrived but it doesn't feel
that contracted they do build one on the
other and it does actually go pretty
well into the overarching story so like
I said it is it is good it is oddly fun
the way that Tales from the Crypt was
oddly morbidly fun so it's a little bit
different I'm I I had
I had to think on a little bit after it
was over before I started recording this
because I was like I'm not sure if I
like it and now I'm thinking like I do
like it I think I had hoped for a harder
gut punch from from Black Mirror for its
its last episode of the of the fourth
season but I think I may now be starting
to experience you know some of the stuff
that led to so many long longtime fans
of Black Mirror who've seen stuff boom
you know prior to season four not liking
metalheads so much because I think the
reason they don't like metalhead is
because it plays against the
expectations that they have built up of
what black mirror is and I'm starting to
develop those expectations and as a
result I see the black museum I'm like
that was fun I'm not sure it felt like
black mirror like so I get the fact that
I had that thought process tells me okay
I'm into the show enough and I've now
seen enough episodes that I'd like oh
I'm at where a lot of my commenters have
been at in terms of their assessments of
some of these episodes where I wasn't at
that point yet I'm not sure how much
else I have to say about this main thing
I mean looking into the more into
specifics of the individual ones a
little bit more though I will say this
the the pain doctor thing the that did
give me the the creepin chills at one
point just by how much they lingered on
when he started inflicting pain on
himself you know with that bit of glass
and the tooth and just the DES lingering
and the bits of blood dropping in the
sink so that even though nothing
shocking about that in terms of like a
twist I saw that coming from a mile away
but yeah they did they did push it and
they knew how to present it in a way
that still made me go so and then I kind
of I kind of like the boner joke and I
liked that she basically called him on
he's like okay I made that part up um
which again fed into you know early on
and you kind of not let your guard down
but you're like not prepared to say
there's something off with this guy
because you hear that and you're like
it's been a theatricality to this guy
you're you're
you're still not sure maybe you'll give
them a pass and of course later on you
know not you not to do that I sort of
talked about the the mind things like
that one bet that one worked decently as
far as the emotional punch of it I think
no not even the emotional the
existential you know horror of that
reminded me a little bit of us has
countless tour in that way and that the
horror of that one with the with her
living in his head and then eventually
getting transferred into the toy that
that's a more existential horror it's
the sort of thing that you actually have
to spend time thinking about more beyond
just what the show shows you to like you
really have it sinking how horrifying
that would be um that said like the
instant it was proposed she'll be in
your head she'll she'll feel what you
feel and see what you see Miami Vice
this is a horrible idea because kind of
what's been fun you know again in a very
dark twisted eye I need to go sit in the
corner and just be alone with my bleak
thoughts for a while kind of fun that is
black mirror is that you know I I
haven't always been certain how the
technology that we're seeing is going to
go wrong which is kind of the wrong
phrase the technology doesn't go wrong
the technology works and in its way
that's what's horrifying in most of
these stories but like the instant I
heard the premise I saw basically every
single way that this was going to not
work out for either of them so even
though I didn't call you know him
transferring her into the monkey and
basically trapping her consciousness
into something that she can't control
and can barely communicate out of you
know all the things that were gonna go
wrong in terms of their relationship I
saw that immediately so thankfully they
didn't drag it out too much and also it
made me think of something that I hadn't
thought about before but I really dig in
terms of Black Mirror in general which
is that they don't get hung up and they
don't eat up screen time with characters
who are like what No
that's not really cause like what would
usually happen it's like if with this
one with that middle story if they had
tried to string it out into a
full-length episode you'd lose minimum
five maybe up to eight minutes on the
neighbor the new girlfriend having it
explained to her that that the mother of
his kid is in his head her not believing
in her maybe proof of it her you know
trying to come to terms with that
concept they skip over all that junk
like everybody in the world gets the
technology even if it's something that
they themselves haven't directly
experienced before we either skip over
whatever disbelief period they have or
they just exist in a world where it's
less of a leap for what they know
day-to-day than it is you know to us and
in the real world so I like that in
general the show does not do the whole
disbelieving thing because I mean what a
waste of time that would be but it's the
sort of thing that a lot of other shows
would would waste time on so that middle
section made me kind of appreciate that
I think that's about it for this one
specifically having finished season four
overall I'm not sure if I can come up
with a full ranking you know what I'll
try down at the bottom is probably gonna
be Archangel I'm and none of these are
bad to be clear but at the bottom most
probably Archangel we're just good it
just didn't the elements that probably
do hit really hard for certain audiences
like if you had a more controlling
parent or if you have a teenager neither
of which is the case for me it probably
hit you harder it didn't quite for me so
that was part that ones down at the
bottom I suppose next up from that would
be it would probably be the black Museum
again it's good but it does feel more
like an episode of Tales from the Crypt
than what I've come to expect out of
black mirror next one up from that would
probably be metalhead which I did really
enjoy up from that is gonna be crocodile
which I didn't enjoy as an experience
watching
but was incredibly well executed and so
I I mean it hit me so hard I can't I
can't put it any lower then then coming
in I guess that third is what I'm up to
now so that puts hanging the deejay
second and USS Callister is my favorite
episode of this season which was also my
very first episode of black mirrors so
maybe that that gives it gives it an
unfair advantage I don't care that's so
my favorite of this season I have
enjoyed this though and I am gonna keep
doing this I mentioned previously black
mirror reviews are going to be a weekly
feature for as long as it takes me to
get through the rest so every Wednesday
until I'm done black mare reviews I'm
going back to the beginning so next week
I will start with season 1 episode 1 and
work my way forward from there so black
mirror the black Museum did you see it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all
those things you know the likes the
subscribes follow me on Twitter send me
an email support my patreon links for
all that stuff is down below so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]